[Music]
i
am a huge fan of the good place wrote
about it
in my newsletter five bullet friday
which went out to a few million people
long long long ago and it was a real
trojan horse for me because
it was recommended to me as a funny show
and that was it and that's how i got
started then i was like wait a second
here
this is a trojan horse for all sorts of
stuff that i would not expect
emmanuel kant didn't see that coming so
what was the pitch
when parks and recreation ended
brooklyn 99 was still on the air
but parks and rec ended and
the people running nbc sort of said to
me like we'd like you to do a new show
and you can kind of do whatever you want
it was one of those deals and we will
guarantee
13 episode season now
even today
the business has changed so much that
that's far more commonplace today than
it was at the time at the time
that was a very exciting kind of oh my
god like they're not gonna make me do a
pilot and then look at the pilot and
then determine whether they're gonna put
it on the air and then order
a small number of them and maybe cancel
it after five if the ratings aren't good
like
all of the sort of pitfalls of a new
show were at least temporarily removed
so
when they made that offer which was very
kind of them
i
had a thought which was like man i kind
of owe it
to
the like myself and i kind of owe it to
like
the idea of being a creative force on
television to try something insane
you know like i had been doing something
essentially the same at that point for a
decade which was writing stories about
a
group of people in a place on earth like
the office was a group of people in an
office in scranton pennsylvania the
parks and rec was a group of people who
worked at a at a government office in
indiana and brooklyn nine-nine
was a group of people who were police
officers and detectives in new york city
and it was like those shows were so fun
and great but they were
within the same general umbrella and i
sort of thought like man i i could do it
again i could come up with
a group of people who are working on the
international space station or a group
of people who work at an ice cream
parlor in belize but
it would be it feels like i've been
given this opportunity and i ought to
take a kind of crazy swing so
they really wanted a family show i had
never done a family show
and so i being a good rule following
soldier
i i put a lot of thought into like what
would it look like for me to do a family
show and the truth is
there's not that much that's very
interesting about my family like i'm
from i'm like
i'm a sort of
middle-class white guy who grew up in
like a suburb of hartford connecticut
and
there is
there's a lot that's been said about
people like me on television and my
family on television and so
i kind of like
i had this idea i had the nascent idea
for the good place rattling around in my
head and had for a couple years like
it's in little tiny pieces
this idea had been kind of like bugging
me
and so
i thought about that and i started it
excited and i developed it on my own
time
and
it just became very obvious like that
was the interesting idea and
of the many many rules of creation
or of writing that have been taught to
me over the years by a number of very
smart people
the the best and most trustworthy
is
write what's interesting like don't try
to don't fake it like if you have to
fake it if you have to try to tell
people that your idea is interesting
then
then you're dead right so like this
it just seemed like the best idea i had
and the most interesting and then that
presented a number of challenges like
for example how do you sell a tv network
on the idea of doing a show that's
explicitly about moral philosophy like
that's a tough sell and so
question number one what is moral
philosophy
yeah yeah and how do you and how does it
work on tuesday at 8 30 on nbc right so
i did a couple things to try to make it
palatable
to my bosses one of them was i worked
way harder and for way longer developing
the idea than i think i would have
normally if i were writing a show about
six goofballs in an office somewhere in
pennsylvania
although
pause for a second to say that greg
worked for an entire year on developing
the office before he ever met with me or
any of the other writers like he put an
enormous amount of work into that show
but
my point is that i worked harder on
figuring out what the story was for the
entire season because they'd given me an
entire season to work with
then i think that i would have normally
i i had the entire season mapped out
before i pitched it the second thing i
did is i talked to ted danson and
kristen bell
who i wanted to play the main parts and
they had expressed interest in playing
those parts so when i went in to pitch
the show
i said here's the show and i laid it out
for them i told them what the pilot
would be i told them what the themes
would be i told them
what what the general arc of the entire
first season would be i was and i said
to them
i've been working on this for a long
time if you have a lot of questions i
promise i'll have answers for you like
there's no aspect of this that i haven't
thought about
i also told him that ted danson and
kristen bell were at least in theory
interested in being in the show which
helped a great deal because once you
have ted dancing and kristen bell in
your show
they don't care what it's about like be
about anything like those are two big
stars right and the last thing i did and
i think the most important thing i did
was i said listen this is a show about
what it means to be a good person
and
the
engine for this the mechanism is the
study of moral philosophy
and that's not going to be like shoved
into the margins
it's not going to be like a casual
reference here and there it's going to
be the the guts of the show it's going
to be in every episode of the show one
of the characters is a moral philosophy
professor who is going to be like
teaching people stuff
and
and i know that that might seem
like a risky idea but i promise you it
will not feel like homework it's going
to be funny
and it's going to be entertaining and i
think that moral philosophy
has uh
in a way that no one maybe would think
at first glance is actually a very funny
discipline to me it's like the thought
experiments are really funny and the
people who invented these theories are
really weird and funny
so i said i promise it won't feel like
homework now that being said the third
episode literally begins with the
character chidi standing at a blackboard
with philosophy 101 written on it and i
was like little boy like
maybe i spoke too soon
but that was how i not only convinced
them to let me do it but also tried to
reassure them that i wasn't going to
bore people to tears that i was like i i
know
this is a show about moral philosophy
but i also fundamentally understand that
it's a half hour sitcom on a major
network that needs to have jokes and
funny stories and plots
that are entertaining and
i kind of just asked them to trust me
and and they did and it was really cool
of them that they let me kind of take
this wild id and run with it
you